hey movie lovers it's me Kevin Smith
come join us on see alive man while we
watch the Bad News Bears together one of
my favorite movies in the world
formative movie for me made me not only
the filmmaker I am today not a very good
one but the man I am today which is more
of a juvenile boy at heart this is the
movie that taught my generation that it
was okay to lose other generations learn
that everyone gets a trophy but not in
1976 man you watched kids look spoilers
lose yes you're gonna watch these kids
lose we're gonna watch them together man
we're gonna tear maan and we're gonna
live chat throughout the entire thing
and you may have a chance to actually do
some face time some one-on-one face time
I'm sure that's via an app of some sort
or maybe it's IRL as the kids used to
say in the late 90s online I don't know
they say anymore so we're all gonna find
out together man how do you do that you
go to see a dot live to get your tickets
man get ready to watch the Bad News
Bears with me April 14th it's gonna be
amazing man go bears North Valley league
bears
[Music]